The one thing that impresses me every
time I go into the sea and it should
impress everyone,
is the abundance of life.
The ocean is not just rocks and water
from the surface,
it looks pretty much the same everywhere
you go.
Sometimes it's a little bluer,
greener or grayer than others,
but most people I think have the
impression that it's all about water and
water of course,
is the key to life.
It's a single non negotiable thing that
life requires,
but because most diverse water is ocean,
you kind of expect that's where most of
life will be in and that's the fact that
is the way it is.
Dive into the ocean.
There's life all the way down.
It's like diving into the history of
life on earth to look around when you're
in the sea because you see not just our
fellow vertebrates,
so there there are plenty of them.
The fish and some cases you have lucky
encounters with whales or dolphins.
You might see turtles,
fellow vertebrates.
You might even see if you're in the
Galapagos islands,
Iguanas,
fellow vertebrates,
but the great sweep of life is mostly
not about vertebrates.
It's about the invertebrates creatures
without backbones starting with a little
tiny things.
The microbes that rule the world,
they were in the ocean in abundance long
before there were organisms that had
multicellular structure,
so having a chance to dive in and to be
aware even though you can't see them,
you know that you're surrounded by this
great sweep of tiny things that generate
much of the oxygen that grab much of the
carbon out of the atmosphere,
the photosynthetic bacteria and other
forms of photosynthetic life that are in
abundance.
In plankton,
you can't really see them for the most
part unless you have high magnification
and divers usually just have a face
mask.
You might see that the water's a little
greener or not.
Sometimes you can actually see little
particles,
but those are relatively large compared
to those really tiny things that even
with the closest look you can deliver
with your eyes.
You really can't see the bacteria that
are there and in great abundance and in
just a,
you know,
a cup of water.
You may have millions of bacteria,
may have a thousand different kinds of
these little microbes.
It looks like water,
but it's still filled with life,
and of course there are the bigger
things.
You're down on the bottom.
You might see sponges.
They've been around for hundreds of
millions of years,
400,
$500,
million years.
You might see starfish.
There are ancient citizens to that.
Go back 500 million years.
You might see jellyfish pulsing by think
about 500 million years,
half a billion years.
Then you see some other creatures that
have taken a little longer to form in
terms of looking at the history of life
on earth.
Horseshoe crabs have a history that goes
back perhaps as much as 400 million
years,
but other arthropods creatures that have
jointed legs,
crabs,
a horseshoe,
crabs aren't true.
Crabs there clip more closely related to
spiders and Scorpions even though
they're out there in the ocean,
but crabs and shrimp and little Copa
pods that feed on the algae,
the photosynthetic things that formed
the basis of much of the great food
chains,
food webs,
and the ocean.
All of that surrounds you as you dive
in.
You see creatures whose history preceded
that have certainly humankind or
anything closely related to us,
maybe sharks or they have a backbone or
back cartilage anyway that have a
history that goes back at least $300,
million years.
We are really newcomers.
Our history is maybe contained within
the last 5 million years or anything
like human civilization.
Think about 50,000 years or really when
you think about civilization with
language and art and things that we
really associate with who we think we
are maybe the last 10,000 years since
the end of the last ice age.
That's nothing in the history of the
earth or life on earth.
As a diver,
you can.
You can think of yourself as almost an
alien.
A newcomer on this ancient planet filled
with creatures whose life preceded that
of humankind by hundreds fruits
of millions of years.